there is a major incident grenfell tower
w11 one wh at the moment the entire
emergency staircase is at light no one
can get in or out of the building
we need people here urgently okay have
you put in contact with a fiber okay yes
yes really now but please like 10 people
[Music]
when we first caught sight of the tower
on a way to the incident it seemed it
was very surreal
it didn't seem like something like that
could be happening in in London because
the fire was already is a really regular
burn pattern it's already up the outside
of the building across multiple floors I
was aware very very very early on that
this was gonna be a tough job I live on
on the second floor on on Granville flat
6 and just about to fall asleep on was
hearing like noises outside so look
through my window to my room on so that
there was a fire a fire engine outside
now I opened my door to find out well
what's going on I saw like couple of of
firefighters on my floor over this able
partner they're on a new baby so it's
like as accident was what was going on
and they told me that there there was a
fire in the club and they had it under
control and they told me well go back
into more flood and stay put and Ola
send someone to 2 to 2 galas I texted
everyone I knew in that building and I
texted everyone that I knew in the area
and I was like what is going on miles on
Facebook I was on on my whatsapp like
just calling texting people in the tower
saying get out cuz everyone could see
what was happening from the outside but
from inside no one could really
understand what I didn't get some
replies and that's obviously the people
that I thought didn't make it out
[Music]
on a night harmon in three times
it's a fire compartment so it's really
hot it's dark you can't see hand in
front of your face because of the smoke
it's noisy lots of people are talking it
was the hardest physical challenge I
have I've ever had to overcome it was
very very hot like 550 degrees Celsius
at floor temperature by the time I got
to where I needed to get to if you
consider you cook a chicken at 220 it
was twice as hot as an oven more than
twice as hot as an oven and that was a
floor temperature ceiling temperatures
that night would have been in excess of
a thousand degrees maybe even as high as
1500 degrees Celsius we would be told
that the fire service were getting ready
to bring somebody down and out who was
seriously injured we would get ourself
mentally prepared and sort of discuss
what actions we would do when that
patient comes out and then sadly none of
those patients ever came out the fire
service were unable to to get them out
alive and they either died in the
building or never got out and it was
really really difficult
[Music]
after 45 minutes no one was coming and
the pad was too like price must open the
window to escape which I did took up my
son wrap a blanket on him take him out
to the window on a climb upon the gate I
climb over the wall and I just reach on
top the gate and Harnam to some someone
some some person I was like you look
after my son
my ex-partner at that time a HealthWorks
gave us words for the window there were
patients with smoke inhalation and sort
of burns injuries and there were
patients with sort of injuries from
trying to escape sir broken bones people
that have had people fall onto them as
they jumped out of the tower
I saw one person who had the remains of
somebody land on top of them as they
were trying to help and you know the
injuries they sustained from that it was
horrific that they're not just the
injuries that they sustained but the
implications of what had happened
[Music]
the closer I got I drove up Latimer Road
and the closer I got the more chaotic if
everything seemed and there was a lot of
shouting there was tears there was panic
and then I saw the fire and it was like
something you see in a disaster movie it
was one of the most shocking sights I've
ever seen
it felt like bedlam because there was a
there was people running about
everywhere and for the most part these
people were busy doing stuff help him
there was people carrying clothes
provision water food everything seemed
to have buzzed into action so quickly
and almost instinctively that was the
other thing the community was cold we
came out with nothing more than a
blanket the community that people come
they give us water
it was nappies the big it was food I
think when I was working with the
volunteers and coordinating the efforts
I was in that zone but when I stood
under the tower and I looked up and I
could see this huge building ablaze and
I could hear people around me saying
there are still people inside there are
still people at the top you just you
everything else just fades away and all
you can think about is those children
those mothers those parents those
families there's those elderly people
that were still trapped in that building
and it's it's one of those feelings
where it just feels sick to the bottom
of your stomach the emotions first hit
me as I was walking back to the fire
engine we were about to leave so we
walked back towards our our truck and as
a young guy came walking down the road
towards us with a baseball cap on and
his hood up and he looked I described
how he looked he looked angry and then
what he did was just look up and hold
out his arms and he gave each one of us
like the biggest hug and that was was
when the emotion
just it hit me like a train and I just
thought wow this this is bad this is
really really bad I remember you know
driving I think the car drove down the
a40 so it's the Westway so you can
clearly see it's like an eye line view
of Grenfell and I just remember seeing
this black building
I remember just bursting out in tears in
the car I saw a lot of anger from some
of the young people in the area this
wasn't this didn't take hours or days to
come out or sources at the moment I got
there there were people who were
extremely well informed and that was why
they were so angry because they knew
precisely that there have been numerous
warnings about something just like this
happening I had to sort of go off social
media a little bit in in the immediate
days after because I didn't want to read
some of the stuff people were putting
out there you know people saying really
really disgusting things like I know I
remember and one comment I saw when he
was actually it became almost a bit of a
narrative for the incident people seem
to feel the need to comment on whether
they thought the people that lived there
were illegal immigrants or not look you
know like that makes any difference to
anything that was going on that night
[Music]
I'm still here temporary coming up to
the tip yeah anniversary annuals promise
that we posed to be permanently housed
I'm still suffering I'm still chomping
hooch to the console and our finals is
unfazed about time that they show some
kind of dignity in us as human beings
for no one to show any care off it's for
the for the the people in power the
council to just disappear and not
support and not be there to answer
questions and not be there to come you
know they completely disappeared after
grandfather left us out to dry there was
there was no support it was literally
just community members on the ground
doing all the work I feel angry I feel
sad I feel this disappointed in the
government as well especially with the
council from day one they promised us to
real house us permanently they can't
expect us mental health physically to
heal and to get better what about
settling ends our home this is the thing
that people need to remember these
aren't figures these aren't facts these
are real human lives
72 human lives recorded as as being dead
from that fire
that's a hell of a lot and that is a
huge impact I think part of the problem
is when you look at the scale of
something as big as groennfell you can't
you can't take it all in at the time and
it takes months and years for you to
actually understand everything that
happened and everything that fed into
that the fire brigade have been
immensely supportive with my mental
health they've offered me and and I
accepted counseling so that I could get
my head back on track because I suffered
with PTSD and depression over the past
few years as a result of grenfell what I
can't forget
that you know scores of people have been
burned alive inside a building that was
managed by the council effectively by
democratically elected politicians who
had been warned repeatedly that
something like this might happen but did
nothing about it
if you live in a country where that can
happen in one part of London then you
live in a country where there's
possibility that could happen everywhere
and you know there are still people all
over the country today who are living in
buildings that are just as dangerous as
Grenfell and it's three years later and
that is a massive scandal the answer to
the question of what justice looks like
has to be answered by families that were
affected by Grenfell I think everyone
else all of us can only try to strive to
support those families to get the
justice that they want they need and
they deserve but I think that answer has
to come from them if it's proved that
there were people making decisions that
they knew you know put people at a
severe risk then they need to be
punished but more importantly than that
than any of those things is that we need
to see policy change so I hope that you
know the inquiry will finally be
concluded and that there will be justice
of a sort and I hope that the people I
met who survived the disaster are
getting on better now and have proper
homes and their lives are getting back
on track but the bigger picture is
nothing much has changed
[Music]
when we most afraid well I was in
obviously in World War two actually
started operating in April 1953 it was
customary for pilots to go on operations
with an experienced crew